[Music]
hey it's Jonah here do you hear yourself
saying I don't have time to work out I
don't have time to go to the gym well
watch this video and do this workout
I've put together a really efficient
workout which you can do at home this
workout combines cardio strength and
rusa core exercises to get your heart
rate pumping to boost your metabolism
and to really target all the muscles in
your body and to hit your core muscles
as well so get your body warmed up and I
promise you at the end of this workout
you will be sweating and you will feel
really good let's do it
there will be three circuits we're going
to start with the cardio circuit so we
will be working for 45 seconds with 15
seconds to rest in between each circuit
will be for eight minutes long okay I
want you to give me your best effort if
at all you feel that you need to stop
and breathe stop and breathe and join
back into the workout so the first
exercise is going to be - jumping jacks
with a Burpee let's go to Jack's alright
go down 1 Burpee - Jack's down 1 Burpee
back to - jacks
very good keep going nice so remember to
pace your breathing and give you a nice
Jack stretch your arms reach your arms
and good so feel your heart rate pumping
this is sort of like your warmup very
good keep going 1 Burpee to jump you
have 10 seconds left
whew breathe in and breathe out this is
only your first workout well done keep
going doing very good one last one and
brick second workout will be side
shuffle ok so I wait - stay low shuffle
to your right
tap shuffle to your left tap and
continue alright so this will really
work on your fight get ready in 3
seconds let's stay low and let's your
shuffle tap
stay low and tap very good tap and tap
so this workout really work on your
thighs and the so your glute muscles
alright as much as you can
stay low do not come up and remember to
pace yourself alright as you progress
then you can speed up the workout good
halfway there do not stop now you're
halfway there
very good feel your thighs feel your
glutes
those are your muscles burning and also
your burning calories
10 seconds left keep going whoa I can't
feel my legs I know how you're feeling
right now one last one
rest it out very good that workout
routine we're going to do a little bit
of upper body cardio so it's going to be
straight punches alright I want to twist
punch to your left twist and punch to
your right
keep both arms up let's go punch punch
punch punch okay strong arms strong
shoulders all right do not drop your
pants okay this is not a punch punch
straight look at your opponent and punch
straight good so tiptoe point your toes
and give me strong punches find your
rhythm very good punch pull it back good
pull it back through your shoulders for
your triceps punch punch punch tight on
those core and twist twist ever further
every time you punch very good what can
I say you say I'm feeling so good yeah
let's keep going
one more and rest it on final find a
cardio workout alright and there will be
repeating the entire set so it's good to
be a switch lunch stand in the middle
all right Oh as you hop are we to touch
in the middle hop and touch all right
let's try it hop touch light down touch
good
so just touch on your knees very good
hop and touch all right study Vee and
slowly we will make it
a bit more challenging so hop and touch
now let's go for your cuffs
go lower lunge lower let's aim for your
cuffs okay good hop and touch
hop and touch very nice give me a deep
lunge switch lunch good switch looks
great
chest up always go back to the middle
and chest up one more and rest it out
we're not stopping right now okay
15 seconds rats we're going back to the
first workout which is 2 jumping jacks
with one purpose all right keep your
heart rate high up we're not stopping
right now give me your best shot you
know all the exercises let's go to
Jack's down one Burpee up three Jack's
down one Burpee very good keep it going
bring your heart rate up keep your heart
rate up and that's when you will burn
calories all right good keep going to
Jack's one Burpee whoa see your sweat
dripping on the floor good halfway there
one Burpee go low up to Jack's down and
oh my god this is a killer I didn't say
it's gonna be easy I promise you you
beat sweaty one last night give me one
more Burpee and up second workout side
shuffle okay so so your right and to
your left work on your thighs and also
your glutes okay breathe in really take
this 15 seconds treasure this 15 seconds
let's go down top double tap good
shuffle double and tap down stay low
alright push your butt back put your
glutes push your butt good keep going
keep moving don't stop right now
whoa look straight ahead
open up your chest pace yourself you can
slow down if you need to but do not stop
almost there breathe in deeply breathe
out ten seconds laughs I can feel your
size and your pain last one more and
rested on Oh upper body cardio straight
punches okay so find your position
remember focus on one target point left
to right okay do not drop your elbows
guard your face
let's go punch pointed twist
tighten your core okay hasn't this part
of your body do not just let it go loose
this is not a punch hide in a corner and
twist and give me those strong punches
very good the harder you punch the
quicker you pull back the more you will
be working on your arms so it's really
up to you how hard you want to push
yourself okay
push push come on punch punch punch
punch good find your rhythm
well I won't see I want to see a badass
Fitness person all right keep going last
three seconds punch punch and rest it on
switch lunch okay so find your point
choose whether you want to touch on your
knees or on your cuffs all right let's
go five seconds and you'll get a break
ready and let's start this side touch
touch okay
so always add a little hop in if you're
a beginner step touch step and touch
okay
if not add a small hop it doesn't have
to be a big hub it's all about finding
your rhythm good tap
and tap if you want to go lower then
touch your ankles all right give me an
even deeper lunge
very good tap tap tap
good keep going your glutes your Hari
tap tap very nice you're almost there
you're gonna get a one-minute break
right after this one more and rest rest
rest
that's your cardio circuit take a
one-minute breather keep yourself
hydrated I am sweating wipe your sweat
we want to move on to the strength
circuit within and without
right we're moving on to the strength to
second for this circuit what you'll need
is a pair of dumbbells I would say
between 4 to 5 kilos each or even three
killers ok so if you don't have any
dumbbells what you can do is just use a
pair of milk bottle and fill them up
with water or rocks all right so your
heart rate should be slightly down but
we want to bring it back up the first
workout is going to be a squat okay with
a shoulder press ok so rotate your
wrists slightly and press it up good so
down give me a deep squat
alright go deep and press it up good
down and press very good
squat down and rotate don't let the
dumbbells touch ok toes point it forward
okay squat and press
so we're combining lower body workout
and those upper body strength workout
don't rush your workout give me nice
proper form chest up
push work on your shoulders and push it
back up good squat down and very good
give me two more ok up last one squat it
down and press it up good second workout
is going to be a lunch with bicep curl
all right so what I want you to do is
step your right leg forward all right as
you come down give me a bicep curl as
you come up bring your arms down let's
go curl up so it's a static lunge with a
bicep curl again we're targeting your
upper and also your lower body good
so really lunch down go low to your butt
all right and feel your biceps working
really hit those glutes right there ban
your legs 90 degrees good down and Kerr
it up and bring it back down good curl
keep your elbows close to your body all
the time alright elbows should be
sticking close to your body chest should
be up do not swing your body that's
wrong so keep it steady down and up down
and
very good few more last one and rest it
out now we're going to get down onto the
floor okay so put your dumbbells down
the next workout is going to be a push
up with shoulder tap okay so choose your
option you can either start on your
knees or get onto your toes ready let's
go push up with show the tap and
alternate push-up show the Ted spread
your legs wider to make the workout
easier alright
the goal of this workout is not to move
your hips too much tap shoe shop a
strong push up and tap again choose your
option you can always start on your
knees I can see my sweat dripping tap
down your shop and tap good keep going
nice solid push up go low very good push
up and really engage your chest muscles
push up tap type in your car find the
balance tap give me two more okay tap
one last one down and good now grab your
dumbbells lie down get into a bridge
alright and we want to do bridge with
chest press okay so bring your butt up
squeeze your butt okay tighten the
glutes and I want you to give me a nice
chest press good tighten the glutes
press up squeeze those butt muscles and
press up again we're working on two
muscles at the same time which is your
glutes and also your chest muscles so
press up elbows lightly tap onto the
floor do not rest your elbows okay
squeeze your butt and get your car lift
the butt up and push your chest and work
on your chest you will also feel a
little bit on your shoulders do not drop
right now I'll squeeze those cheeks good
keep going last few more give me at
least three more solid chest press two
more last one more and good get back up
right now we're not stopping we're
getting back into the first two workout
right let's go show the press okay with
a squat ready let's go give me a nice
deep squat toes pointed forward deep
squat and press it up good deep squat
twist your wrist slightly rotate your
wrist and press it up
type in your core good press push your
butt back really push your butt back and
push up with your heels all right I am
sweating and you shoot to be sweaty as
well okay if the weights are too light
then you can go heavier it is too heavy
then choose a lighter weight as you
progress
then slowly increase okay squat deep
squat and press it up good keep going
look very good up press use of the
strength from your legs and also your
shoulders give me one more alright one
more press good right now let's lunge
and with a bicep curl let's go on our
left leg now okay so let's look forward
alright start high up as we go down give
me one bicep curl okay static lunge
let's go down curl up down and up good
so nice straight pointed forward and
curl good very good keep your body
straight tighten your core straight body
feel your legs feel your glutes go low
let your knee your right knee to touch
the floor gently and come back up tap
gently and come back up
very good curl elbows again close to
your body breathe you got this okay
you've got this your sweat is your fat
trying keep going you got this and let's
get back down onto the floor for
shoulder tap three shots so let's get
down put your dumbbells down and get
into a push-up position choose your
option okay nice or you're toast let's
go toast
push-up
and tap okay spread your legs slightly
to balance your core down and attack
remember minimal hip movement down and
tap gently down and touch good push-up
is a great workout I know we all hit it
but it is an excellent operative working
ok tighten those carp do not drop or dip
your hips all right
don't dip your low back look at my sweat
leg it's just all over the mat right now
oh and down ok every sweat every effort
you put into you will only get closer to
your goal last one tap and lie back down
let's get into a bridge with chest press
so lie down okay lift your butt up start
high up dumbbells up and ready let's go
down and push up down and push up good
squeeze this is your final workout for
the strength circuit so give me your
best effort balance find the strength
find the balance in your arms and also
your wrist if you're new to this workout
you will find that your wrists are
wobbling okay that's okay it takes time
to strengthen your joints as well so
keep going stick your butt up
type in your car and give me a nice
chest press slow control down press up
control and press up good few more press
up down squeeze those butt cheeks down
and up very very very well done drop the
weights okay
take again a one-minute break you have
one more final second which is your call
work out okay keep yourself hydrated and
we want to move on to the final eight
minutes circuit for your car all right
20 seconds left this is your final call
circuit okay so it's going to be a
combination of some really static
movement but also with dynamic movements
so the first workout is going to be a
plank walk so I wanted to walk to one
side and give me a hop left and right
okay and walk back all right so start in
the center ready let's go walk hop in
left and right and walk back good and
tuck me in good walk back in in and out
good again and let's keep going okay so
this movement again it will increase
your heart rate and it will increase the
calorie burn so just like any other
plank you want to always make sure your
body is nice and flat
and that you suck your belly in hold
back tuck in in and back good keep going
only 5 seconds left walk out in in and
walk one more in and in good right cycle
work out let's lie down onto the floor
alternate leg Lafe ok right I'm gonna
push my mic slightly so I want you to
crunch up alternate the leg up together
and alternate okay so choose the option
you can choose to bend your knee if you
want to read your knee one at a time or
if you want to keep your leg straight
and up and down very good so alternate
leg and just keep crunching up and down
ok so don't press your heels on the
floor but again
if you want an easy option you can just
tap gently bring it up tap and bring it
up okay good
so keep crunching through your upper abs
and your lower abs really burning add at
the same time together
breathe in and breathe out keep going
and drop your legs shake it out a little
bit rest it out now bring your body up
we want to go for alternate knee tucks
so palms facing forward pumps on to the
floor
all right legs out straight again bring
your legs up okay give me alternate knee
tucks and just crunch and in bring your
knees as close as you can to your body
and just pick it back up pick it back up
and up so just gently support your upper
body with your pumps okay so it's all
about really keeping the lower abs good
keep going and keep alternating very
good haha at the final ten seconds we
want to do double knee tucks alright
keep going crunch in and now good double
me out
double knee out double out double out
last two more one more
and now face down let's go it's going to
be a straight arm Superman so this is
going to work on your lower back muscles
okay I'm straight out legs straight out
as you bring your body up squeeze your
cheeks squeeze your lower back
straight down look down and squeeze good
again up and squeeze so look down and
squeeze really feel your lower back
keep those legs straight keep those arms
straight and gently tap to the back
breathe in and out whoo good squeeze as
high as you can bring a bag as high as
you can lift your chest off the floor
this is workout number four you can see
that the entire mat is literally covered
in my sweat let's not stop right now
okay let's get back up into plank walk
with knee tucks okay this is your final
four minutes all right
so and strong let's go start in a high
plank okay we want to walk to one side
and lunataks right start in the center
let's go what in and in good walk back
left and right in and out good and walk
in and out okay guys remember this is a
four week workout challenge for you if
you don't have time it's all about doing
shots if this don't work out which
combines cardio strength and also core
good all you need it's less than 30
minutes which includes your warmup and
also your cooldown so I don't want to
hear any excuses alright keep going
pace your breathing last few more this
is you'll find a plank walk and final
tucks out and walk and get it down let's
lie down onto the mat alternate lake
race okay choose your option hands up
and start with your legs up okay and
ready let's go down and tap down and
reach down and reach very good point
your toes point your toes leave
your shoulders off the floor and breathe
okay every time you bring your legs up
breathe out breathe in breathe out good
good keep going all right very very nice
without last ten seconds give me your
best effort fill the score don't drop
right now feel it embrace it and relax
ultimately tugs up support your upper
body with your pumps okay and when your
legs
give me alternate detox and let's go
straight out and go in out okay so it's
like cycling but obviously you're
controlling your upper body as well do
its alternate find your rhythm kick out
and point your toes good relax upper
body relax your shoulders okay and just
focus on your core okay every time it's
hurting that's when you want to push
more all right
it's not about stopping it's about
pushing through very good
all right last ten seconds we want to go
for double knee tucks ready let's go
double and double good bring it in out
in and out last one and one more in good
face down one final 45 seconds all right
Superman with straight arms okay work on
your lower back your low back it's also
part of your car then breathe in
let's go squeeze down chest up squeeze
tap and comes together
good give your legs off the floor
squeeze the glutes squeeze the lower
back
Oh rich and swim very good swim tug it
on lower back good ah you have only 15
seconds laughs okay you have survived
through at least 26 minutes or a gout
and just cool down right after this keep
going not stopping right now okay
breathe in and out squeeze lift it
higher rest it out and just come up all
right stretch it out very well done you
have done a combination of cardio
strength and OSA core exercises okay all
under 30 minutes I hope you're sweating
I hope you can see a sweat dripping and
I hope that your heart rate is still
pumping okay so do some stretching do
some 5 to 10 minutes a gentle stretches
COO your body down bring your heart rate
back down and then you can start or end
your day it's not about working out for
many hours but rather it is about making
your workout efficient okay so do this
for weeks
hold the body fat burning challenge let
me know how you get on in the comments
below like this video share this video
with a friend it get them to join you
and be sure to hit the subscribe button
if you haven't yet done it and you can
check out a lot more workouts on my
channel and also crazy workout
challenges which I trust you will have
fun all the best